[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on
Christie I'm so excited to talk to you
guys we're excited to talk to you I just
have to say I just have to say you guys
are my favorite Duo don't tell anybody
right we're gonna tell everyone
especially
Ken I'm so excited and I just can't hide
it all right so go for it what's
up so okay I'm wondering if I should
which I think I know the answer but I'm
wondering if I should go into debt to
prioritize my health so I'm not dying I
just got a diagnosis of polycystic
ovarian syndrome and that has the
potential to affect my fertility I'm not
trying to have kids yet I'm just trying
to be proactive so that once I do try to
have kids I don't have any issues when I
knew there was a problem I could have
prevented so the um treatment that I
want to do is 39 $900 paid in full and I
checked before I was like I see you use
a firm is there interest and they were
like no but it's a $600 payment that you
have to make to qualify for zero
interest um and so I have only $177,800
in debt student loan debt that's it um
and then of course our house we did the
whole thing we sold the cars we sold the
guns we had a garage sale like my
husband and I it went really really hard
um to get some of that taken care of um
and so we're committed and I'm I ask
myself all the time because I don't get
to call you guys every day what would
what would the the Ramsay personality
say to me yeah
and my thought is that okay I'm not
dying prioritize your health in the ways
that you can and kids kids are important
to you yes of course yeah um look okay
so you've got the 17 you got almost
$88,000 in student loan debt do you have
other debt laying around no okay what do
you guys earn what's your combined
income so our combined income we do we
do own a house and we only have $1,000
emergency found that was a mistake but
whatever um well you're walking through
the baby steps so I get it okay right we
earn so I earn 47 my husband earns
68 so next we take home we take home
about like 7,000 a month which is
awesome okay and then we have two um
18-year-old girls that were kind of
mentoring and helping um living with us
so um Elizabeth who has kind of like
become like almost like a surrogate
daughter is paying 400 and then the
other Elizabeth is paying 900 a month so
they pay you 4900 okay yes so we're
taking home almost 8300 a month yeah
okay um so here's what I would do simp
and you tell me I'm going to tell you
what I think the solution is and you
tell me why you think it won't work or
why you think it will work um I would
pause the debt snowball and I would save
up for this procedure and I pay cash for
it right now yeah today this
month okay because this is not just
about kids this is a complicated thing
and you know I'm sure you went down the
Google rabbit
hole no I didn't you did it good for you
wow I did some research I was like okay
because when I got the diagnosis I was
like are they sure like I was like did
they get because I had no symptoms I was
so confused I don't have um painful
Cycles like I I'm a very healthy person
and so I was like really um and so I did
some research and then I just went to my
doctor and I was like what the heck's
going on she kind of shut me down and
that's why why I want to go like the
naturopathic route yeah because I'm like
I don't feel respected well I I would I
would get a second medical opinion
before I did that okay so I'm I'm
talking to you like I would talk to my
sister you do whatever you want to do
okay um if you're my sister and you
called me and said hey my doctor won't
listen to me shut me down I would say
cool they've cashed out um not that your
doctor isn't right and you're wrong I
think we have a culture now that goes to
YouTube first and then challenges
somebody with with a medical degree and
we're like you're like I I have buddies
that are Physicians and they're dealing
with us all the time but I also know
there's a shutdown you're stupid and I'm
not and I'm not having that either right
so I would make an appointment and get a
second
opinion um this is a a procedure that
often when they go looking it might not
be nearly as bad as the um as the um
MRIs would suggest or it can be
infinitely more complicated and so I
think saving up for that procedure like
Jade said just pause The Babys this is
your health and this is kids is one part
of this but this is systemic man and you
this is about you being healthy in a
bunch of bunch of ways not just having
kids one day so I'd go get that checked
out how does this
you sorry how does it how's what John
and I saying is it hitting right do you
feel like yes yeah so it's not it's not
a procedure it's just it's me it's
really hormone testing and then deciding
how I'm going to be eating differently
based on that hormone testing I would do
a lot lot of research before you go down
that road okay and I am dude I I have
sat an arguments with my medical doctor
researcher buddies and we have gone
round and round and round and round and
there is a lot and it pains me to say
this because this was my entire identity
there's a lot of snake oil out there
there's a lot of Right Stuff okay and
hormone testing is critically
important but okay um sometimes a
medical doctor is wrong and sometimes a
medical doctor will shut you down
because they hear it 5,000 times a day
because people Google too much stuff
right that's where a second opinion is
going to be super important and being
honest with your physician and saying
here's what I'm thinking about
doing and please don't shut me down but
I'm scared about this other this other
path um and go that route but
$3,900 for some
specialized essential oil testing is is
messy and I know I just made everybody
mad sorry James the mean comments are
going to come um hormone testing is
important it's it's good but man look I
and and just for anybody listening if
you want to have a baby you can pause
the baby steps whether it's fertility
treatments whether it's adoption and
you've got to save up it's okay you
don't have to be debt free before you
have a family and I just want to say
that loud and clear some people it's
their personal choice if they want to
hold off on a family and pay off their
debt first but hear me loud and clear
that's personal choice we are never
going to shake our finger at you for
pausing paying off debt to have a baby